my name is miles kramer i'm a graduate
student at princeton
um i work at the intersection of physics
and machine learning i usually apply
machine learning to different problems
in astrophysics and also
kind of develop new methods that might
be used for different problems so
today i want to talk to you about this
method we've developed for
taking a deep neural network and kind of
converting it
into a simple analytic expression
so so this is work with these
collaborators
um so let me just start by if you
remember nothing else from this talk i
want you to remember uh these three
points
so the first is uh symbolic regression
it's it's kind of like it's it's an
underused machine learning model
but it's it's very very interpretable
and it's very good at
doing physics problems so symbolic
regression is a machine learning
algorithm where you basically learn to
model your data set
by searching the space of analytic
expressions
so one can convert a
deep neural network into an analytic
expression with the technique i'm going
to show you today
and this i think this represents a very
strong way
of interpreting a neural network so i
think a lot of
traditional explainable ai techniques
they look at
kind of indirect interpretability kind
of seeing what the model's doing but
this is
a very strong way of actually converting
your model into a
fully interpretable equivalent model
that you can work with so like a simple
analytic expression
so the last thing i want to say is that
i think our method also represents
a it's a way of doing symbolic
regression on high dimensional data
where symbolic regression would
typically be completely intractable
so what is symbolic regression it is a
machine learning algorithm
so you so it's uh we usually do it for
regression problems we want to fit
uh the relation between an input set of
features an
output set of features so
except the basis so traditionally
machine learning you have some
model that depends on many parameters
and you would fit those parameters
symbolic regression you're actually
fitting this
space of analytic expressions so
uh so you you search over all the space
of analytic expressions for this
function f
uh that that models this relationship
so okay if you have this curve
so x-axis is your input y-axis is the
output
you want to find a model that could fit
this
in symbolic regression what you would do
is you would say
you would try basically different
functional forms so you say does cosine
fit this
no does sine fit this no uh you keep
trying you get to exponential of x
so that's closer and now what you do
is you kind of uh you reward that
expression
and you would basically start mutating
on that expression
and you would eventually find exponent
over
x over two which is the right expression
um
so so so why do we want to do this
so if you think about it
many many rules in in physics and in
natural sciences in general
are kind of accurately described by
simple symbolic expressions
so this is already true so this is some
cheat sheet that i pulled off of google
for physics
physics 101 and you can see that so many
different expressions
in this cheat sheet are just simple
analytic equations
and they are extremely precise at
describing these relationships
so i think i really think the question
is like like why don't we use this basis
it's such a good basis for physics it's
so interpretable
it's so concise and easy to compute
really
why don't we use this as a basis in
machine learning that's
that's what i see the motivation for
symbolic regression so
there's this really nice article by
eugene wigner he basically says
the miracle of the appropriateness of
the language of mathematics for the
formulation of the laws of physics
is a wonderful gift which we neither
understand nor
deserve we should be grateful for it and
hope that it will remain valid in future
research
in that it will extend for better for
worse to our pleasure even though
perhaps also to our bafflement
to wide branches of learning so in this
article he points out
kind of all the weird connections
between different
scientific fields like like pi
appears in the formula for a circle and
it also appears in a
normal distribution there's a lot of
weird connections in math
and it really seems like these analytic
expressions are just a powerful basis
for describing our universe so okay
still why
so concise interpretable you can apply
centuries of mathematical analysis to
kind of detect
failures in your model ahead of time and
um and another thing we've we've also
seen in our work is that
they may generalize better to
out-of-distribution
data than the neural network they were
extracted from
for physical problems and this this
might be due to neural networks
with relu activations maybe you only get
like linear extrapolation whereas
when you convert to this analytic basis
you might get
kind of better extrapolation properties
okay so so how does symbolic regression
actually work
so if i have uh if i have this
expression
x1 x4 plus cos x2 minus 0.32
i would represent this in a genetic
algorithm package for symbolic reaction
as
a binary tree so you can decompose it
into a binary tree
so this is so my package piscer this is
how it represents an equation
other packages like cindy you would fit
a sparse sum of a
basis set of functional forms and kind
of find a sparse
set of coefficients you can also do this
genetic algorithm strategy
so in the genetic algorithm strategy the
way it works is you have this
binary tree represent an equation and
you apply different mutation operators
from genetic algorithms so like you take
your
your multiplication symbol you mutate it
to a division symbol
maybe you take your cosine and you just
delete it from the tree
maybe you take your x2 and you mutated
to x
or you take your x1 mutated to x2 maybe
you take a constant and like randomly
increase it by twenty percent decrease
it by twenty percent maybe you swap the
sign
so you have all these random mutations
to um
explore expression space
um so i i use
regularized evolution in in my paiser
package
so in this case you fit um some small
sub sample of a population of equations
and you would find the fittest member of
that subsample so that the
equation that best fits your data and
you
you mutate it so in this case you're
mutating the
you're mutating the constant and
you would basically look for the oldest
member of your population and replace it
with your with this new expression and
you
just repeat this thousands and thousands
of times
and this is a way of kind of if
kind of more efficiently exploring
equation space than just
a brute force search so you would score
this and repeat
so so how can i actually do symbolic
regression so there's so if you know
like
your equation is going to be a sum of
known functional forms i think cindy is
a is a faster approach
it's a really good approach for finding
a sparse
set of coefficients in front of a basis
set of functional forms when you
when you don't know your functional
basis or you you think it could be like
a very nested
nasty expression um i think a good
choice might be piscer which is my
package which uses
um genetic algorithms so they both have
kind of areas of
of strength um so the way paiser works
is a it's a python package with a julia
back end
so if i have this input data set with
with a hundred data points and five
features and say
my true equation is like 2 cos x 3
plus x0 squared minus 2 i would put that
into piscer
declare what binary operators are
allowed
declare what unity operators are allowed
i can also define
a custom operator that it can use
and i i let it do this genetic algorithm
search
um and in the end so this one is
actually really fast because you don't
have that many features
you don't have that many operators um so
it can find this in like 10 minutes
um just by kind of applying genetic
algorithms to search the space
okay so so something something
really important with symbolic
regression is that
you get so they're compact you get
explicit interpretations they generalize
well
but they are terrible at high
dimensional problems
and this is because you're dealing with
uh combinatorics you're
like if you count the number of possible
equations there's
just like a factorial number like
factorial
over the number of features so it blows
up very very fast
so it's bad at high dimensional problems
whereas say
deep learning is kind of like uh
it's precisely complements this you are
efficient at learning in high
dimensional spaces but you are
uninterpretable bad at generalization um
and so you can see how these kind of
complement each other so
what we were really interested in is can
we combine both
can we take the strengths of both of
these and
maybe use deep learning to kind of find
a better
symbolic expression so this is what we
did so
we uh in our approach you
basically train a neural network to
solve your problem because they're
really good at high dimensional problems
you train in your network to model some
data set
and you basically want to take that
trained model
and try to distill it into a simple
analytic expression
so you're basically rather than fitting
the equation on the raw data itself
you're fitting the expressions to the
neural network
and then the nice part about this is
uh you can you can train the neural
network with different regularizations
that causes it to be easier for the
symbolic regression to
kind of distill so like
the way you actually want to do this is
you structure your neural network
so that it's built up of small
internal functions and each internal
function you want to have
operate on a low dimensional space
and since it operates on a low
dimensional space
that means that symbolic regression
becomes tractable
because now you're in the low
dimensional regime
and you can actually run symbolic
regression on the neural network
you kind of treat the neural network as
like a the internal functions like a
data
data generating process and you try to
approximate it
um so as an example like if you
if your internal function in your neural
network is like y
equals the sum of g of x i where g
is your learned maybe it's like a
multi-layer perceptron
in this example um you would
you would regularize g to be to have a
sparse output
so you want g to live in a low
dimensional space
be like a low dimensional function and
then it's really easy
to kind of you want to kind of rip out g
of your model you like rip it out and
then you try to fit
symbolic expressions to it so another
example
this is actually this is a this is very
similar to kind of like a graph net
you have this this one multi-layer
perceptron
that you sum over your data site so
you're summing the encodings of your
data set
and then you map that sum in the
original node
through a different multi-layer
perceptron so in this example
you would want both g and f to live in
low dimensional spaces
because then it's it's easy uh to
distill them into a symbolic expression
okay so so another way of saying our
method
is you want to you want to design a
neural network
such that it has separable internal
functions inside of it
so rather than kind of huge latent
spaces
you want to have you want to distill
smaller latent spaces and have several
internal functions and when you do this
and when you train it with a
sparsity regularization on the latent
spaces
then you can try to approximate those
internal functions with symbolic
regression
so you approximate those internal
functions and then
you compose those symbolic expressions
uh
using those using the internal structure
so like if you have some pools inside
your network you would have those sump
pools
inside the extracted equation too so you
want to
compose those symbolic expressions and
in the end you're left with a
symbolic model that is equivalent to
your neural network
um so consider like a graph neural
network so this is a
single message passing step graph
network you have your
function g which is like maybe a
multi-layer perceptron
takes the sending node or sorry that's
the receiving node
the sending node is inputs and it
outputs some message
you some pull those messages over the
receiving
for the receiving node and then you pass
that into a second function
which takes that summed message the
current node state
and maps it into a new node state so in
this example you would want g
to have a low dimensional
input space and output space so
you would kind of regularize that during
training to achieve that goal and then
it's very easy to do symbolic regression
on it
so we did this for many different n-body
systems
we have like simple particles
interacting with springs
or maybe gravitational laws you try to
predict their dynamics with a graph
network
and you you encourage this low
dimensional representation
and then you apply symbolic regression
to this function g
and you end up with you find the
analytic expression you find
is actually equivalent to the to the
true one from your simulation
so it's a way of converting this trained
graph network into an analytic
expression it ends up being the true
expression so it's very interpretable
obviously this would generalize very
well because it's
literally the true simulator um so i
think it's a nice way of doing things so
another way to look at this is kind of
like like a graph network
has a strong analogy to new tony
mechanics
so the the latent space of the messages
is kind of like it's kind of like a
force so you're summing over
the uh sending nodes it's kind of like
you're summing over interacting
particles
and that's kind of like you're computing
the net force
so basically uh when we regularize
sparsity in this message domain
we're basically like encouraging it to
find the force vector
because that's that's a low dimensional
representation
and then your node model might end up
being the acceleration
so you would you would approximate both
the edge model the known model
and convert those uh
with symbolic regression into an
equation
okay so so we tried this for many
different uh
data sets so we have like one over r
squared one over r
spring law we even have an if statement
describing a force law
so this is a really nasty kind of
interaction law
and so we can get we can actually
recover those expressions
so we start by generating these
simulations of maybe particles connected
by springs
so these are different simulations
recorded over time
and this is the true force law so we
learn to predict these dynamics
with a graph network so you observe and
you can see
over time they get closer and closer to
the true dynamics
just from the graph network learning
this regression problem now what we also
do is we regularize the internal
functions of the graph network
to have small dimensional latent spaces
so you see it kind of pushes this
so that it puts as much information to
as few dimensions as possible
um so it sparsifies the light in space
so one thing you can do is just fit the
forces to those messages
and it turns out that it's actually
those
messages are actually a rotation of the
true forces
so you can see it's it's almost a
perfect correlation
when you have this rotation so if if
this law is unknown
rather than fitting the force you would
apply symbolic regression
so you would kind of fit these messages
and you can see you extract this
expression it's the rotated spring law
which is pretty cool so we can we can do
this for many different systems
we can recover spring law one over r
squared
we can even recover like nasty
discontinuous forces
we also did this with uh hamiltonian
neural networks
so we have this like hamiltonian graph
network and we can recover
the interaction hamiltonian between two
particles
the actual analytic expression which is
pretty cool um
so we also so being an astronomer i
i kind of interested in this technique
to to apply it to astrophysical systems
so we have this this dark matter
simulation this
very kind of uh this very large
dark matter simulation over many
different cosmologies
and we try to basically predict
the dark matter over density at the
center of
a dark matter halo and so we can
convert the graph network into an
analytic expression we get this
this cool kind of over density
expression
and it turns out it's more accurate than
than um
kind of the the most intuitive
expression you could write down
so you can see that kind of
counter-intuitively you're dividing by
mass where you would expect to multiply
by mass
so you can actually you can start to
kind of
think about how you would theoretically
get this result which is pretty cool and
you you
you really can't have that discussion
with a normal neural network
you can only really discuss these kind
of these scaling relations
when you do symbolic regression on your
graph network so it's
very interpretable in terms of existing
physics
you get good generalization which we
observed um
it's it's of course accurate it's
compact it's a really nice expression so
we did this
we tested this kind of like wignerian
prior idea so when you convert it into
an
expression even though it's not the true
expression necessarily
because it's like this this dark matter
relation you would not expect this to be
a true relationship because it's kind of
just it's kind of just a correlation
but when you actually measure the
generalization to out-of-distribution
data
against the graph network it destroys
the graph network
like this analytic expression is much
better at generalizing
out of distribution data and i think
that's something that's really
interesting
as we go forward in developing machine
learning for physics
so restatement you make a neural network
you try to have multiple internal
functions
that each work on a low dimensional
space
you then approximate that
function with a symbolic equation so you
can use
like cindy for if you know your basis
functions piscer if you don't um and
then you try to compose those symbolic
expressions together
and that's kind of an equivalent
interpretable model so
so one thing some people ask us is why
don't you do straight symbolic
regression you have this
you have the sum pool um maybe you can
learn
this expression in this expression
simultaneously the the problem with this
is that
you square the number of possible
equations it's already a hard problem to
do this with symbolic regression
for just just one of these equations but
now you're kind of
squaring the number because you're
fitting them simultaneously whereas with
the neural network
you can fit z and y i simultaneously
very fast just
by a chain rule so you only get two to
the nine
two times ten to the nine possibilities
because you fit them separately
um so it's it scales much better
um so uh we we
developed this technique last year we've
been applying it to different
um problems in astrophysics so one is
like finding
optimal observables for cosmic voids you
can actually extract
a analytic expression for the
property of a void which is kind of most
uh
which provides the most information for
predicting
uh cosmological properties so this is
with christina
pablo and niall led this really cool
work um
where they they find newton's law from
real solar system data and they also
learn
the planetary masses from scratch so we
have to kind of give
the masses to the graph network but they
actually can
learn the masses which is really cool
so the another application is we're
trying to apply this graph network
approach to fluid dynamics
where you basically train the graph
network on some turbulence problem
and then you try to extract the pdes
from the graph network
so obviously like these are all
expressions from the same equation
um this is a lot more difficult so we've
we've been developed some
techniques to get this working this is
with elaine
this is also kind of a really cool
application of this idea
so again the takeaways are symbolic
regression machine learning algorithm
where you can
you can model your data with analytic
expressions so it's much
more interpretable it might provide
better generalization for physics
you can always kind of convert a deep
neural network into an analytic
expression with this
technique i described and i think this
is a very strong way of interpretation
this also represents a good way of doing
symbolic correction on high dimensional
data whereas normal symbolic regression
kind of
uh it scales scales badly
um so our code we have a tutorial
online uh piscer this symbolic
regression package i used
it's on github as well yeah thanks for
listening
i'm interested to see kind of what
applications people do with this
technique thank you